we have to end off on some good vibes of
course courtesy of one of my favorite
people Brendan Frazier who's in Toronto
over the weekend premiering his upcoming
film The Whale at Tiff and be sure to uh
watch my sit down with Brendan tonight
amazing Canada it's so good thank you
all right
um that's it all right we must say
Brendan is getting some major Oscar buzz
for this role the film got a five minute
standing ovation and the praise
continued as Brendan was awarded with
the tribute award the highest honor at
Tiff yeah I love this Brendan accepted
the honor at the Tiff tribute Awards on
Sunday where he got a little emotional
in his acceptance speech take a look
thanks for joining us thanks for your
great comments we'll see you back here
next time oh my running shoes
foreign
wow
this is thank you
I think that the last time that I waited
to hear my name called aloud to receive
an award
was in grade four
and it was from the Peewee bowling
league
um I must thank you for keeping me in
the job that I love
because it's nice work if you can get it
thank you to everyone at Tiff especially
Cameron Bailey
um
I just I want you to know how deeply I
appreciate this affirmation
thank you thank you thank you for this
tribute of word performance it means a
heck of a lot more to me than a
participation bowling trophy
um okay I'm one more thing
um
I know not all that may be coming
but be it what it will
I will go to it laughing
that was our friend Herman Melville in
1851.
it's just been upcycled for you by your
friend Brian Foster
Toronto International Film Festival
2022. thank you have a laugh on me
you've earned it thank you